john the legend hello hey
let's talk about this album first i want
to talk about the album cover yes
because it's not lost on me you're
shirtless i am shirtless yes it's not
lost on me either how did we get here
well uh we shot a lot of things uh we
shot a lot of outfits and and you'll see
some of the outfits throughout the album
uh cover and the jacket but um it felt
like
the
shot of me shirtless just felt like
it was me kind of un encumbered
unadulterated
pure and the album title is legend so
it's it's me
it's self-titled and uh it's me in my
purest form my most honest form and so
we figured i should be
shirtless for the cover too okay wow
here we are here we are
so it's called legend you're a young
legend
okay yeah do you feel like well i was
calling myself legend before i even had
a record deal so i was very presumptuous
of me but it was a nickname that a guy
named jay ivey first called me and uh
we eventually decided to run with it as
a stage name
and um i wasn't planning to change my
name i was john stevens and i was fine
with coming out as john stevens but once
we started uh
playing with the name john legend we
were like yeah this is better
it'll make my presence felt more it'll
announce my presence before i show up
but it will give me a lot to live up to
because um you know who calls himself a
legend before they even have one hit one
album out one anything um but we did it
and uh it was really just me betting on
myself hoping that things would work out
and not going into it expecting to fail
or worried about failure but saying i'm
gonna go out there and try to live up to
this name and that's what i've been
trying to do since then you did it
we're here we're here
what did you want to say with this album
what was your approach well
a lot of it was just
having the time to write and and to
collaborate and to create because we
were in this
house my studio's upstairs and uh the
pandemic was still raging uh the
vaccines were just coming online so
people were starting to kind of look
forward to the ability to get back
together again but uh we were still not
touring yet and so i had a lot of time
to write yeah um and this was the most
productive and creative period of my
life
and um i wrote more songs in you know
2021 through early 2022 than i've ever
written in that same amount of time
before and um
the songs represent the gamut you know
it's kind of some of them are more
celebratory and festive and you know the
idea of us looking forward to getting
back out and going to parties again and
celebrating each other again and then
some of them you know are more
introspective and romantic about those
quiet moments we have with our loved
ones and i wanted all those sides of me
to be represented in the album and
that's why i self-titled it that's why i
made it a double album so
we could really fully see all the
different sides of my artistry and all
the things that made me the artist i am
and that's what we've created with
legend you also work with ryan tedder
who's obviously work with the adele's
and the beyonces and the taylor swifts
are they on your bucket list i'm sure
you can text all of them
well i don't text well adele is close
with chrissy and they text each other
and um
the rest of them like i know very well
we've
uh interacted at different events i've
even performed at taylor swift's concert
before with her and uh taylor's been on
the voice with us and um
i just truly respect all of them so much
and and
the connective tissue of course is ryan
has worked with everybody and uh ryan is
such a smart artist such a great
songwriter great producer and also just
knows everybody so working with him is
such a joy because you're just able to
do so much between the two of us we know
everyone we both come at music
differently we have different
perspectives but when we come together
it really complements each other really
well and he was so fun to work with on
this album he was involved very
thoroughly like he was either co-writing
with me helping me pick the songs
helping me figure out collaborators uh
it was a really fun process of
completing the album with him he's a
great producer yeah and you're an egot
winner yes period yes energy yes kidding
they can't take that away
honestly that's insane yeah that is
really weird there are 17 of us
wow in history in history yes where do
you keep these awards well we have some
upstairs i have five grammys upstairs
but most of my trophies are at home uh
in my piano bar oh yes have the kids
ever broken one or damaged one my nephew
when he was young
he uh he's a star receiver for uh the
minnesota golden gophers now he's a a
college athlete now uh but when he was
young
he and his uh other cousin were
roughhousing around our apartment in new
york and they knocked a shelf over and
broke one of my grammys and so we had to
get it replaced
oh yes what a call to me but these are
my oldest two nephews and now they're
both 22. they were like nine when this
happened yeah uh they're both 22 now and
uh they're making me proud every day one
of them's a musician one of them's a
really successful athlete and uh uh
they're going on to do great things in
life and i try to help them as much as i
can but yeah they broke my grammy
oh my goodness have your kids showed any
signs of singing do they sing around the
house um luna loves to sing she's always
singing she sings in the car every song
she like remembers lyrics and sings the
melody really well so she has she can
carry a tune for sure i don't know if
she wants to do it uh for real
um but she sees me performing all the
time and and i think she gets inspired
by seeing the show
and we'll see if she ever wants to do it
for a living but part of me is like i'd
rather them do something that um they
can be
themselves and not feel that pressure
uh of being my kid and trying to do the
exact same thing that i did in the exact
same field that i do it in so i'm open
to both possibilities them them going
off and doing their own thing or them
falling in my footsteps but i'll warn
them that this is not easy and the fact
that they're my kid is is going to open
some doors but they still will have to
prove themselves as an artist uh
regardless yeah i mean when your dad's
an ego
like best of luck it's a lot of pressure
you know and i i feel like i might be
happier if they are able to just do
their own thing and not yeah try to do
exactly what i do yeah and
congratulations chrissy's expecting
absolutely very excited i feel like
everyone is like rooting for you guys
yeah well you know everyone's seen the
ups and downs you know we have two
beautiful kids and um we lost um a
pregnancy a couple years ago and we
communicated that with the rest of the
world because they knew we were pregnant
and for the baby to just disappear and
let's not say anything it would have
been weird so we felt like we should
tell people we were going through this
when we experienced this loss and we're
mourning and what ended up happening is
we got this avalanche of love from
people and also we heard from so many
people that have gone through the same
thing
but were
hesitant about sharing it before and and
felt some shame uh and felt like it was
something they kept quiet rather than
share with the world
and i think chrissy's sharing it opened
up the conversation for a lot more
people to talk about this kind of loss
that they have experienced but were you
know hesitant to talk about i feel like
wonder woman is about chrissy yeah it's
like an ode to her but it you know i
wrote it with other writers too and it
was a collaboration and what we talked
about a lot was our moms too you know
and the idea of celebrating mothers and
grandmothers and all those women who are
important in our lives that make our
lives better and make us better people
and um that's what the song is really
celebrating and seeing chrissy go
through
pregnancy losing a pregnancy being a
great mother and just knowing just how
much women have to carry so often and
how often they're underappreciated we
wanted to make a song that celebrated
them that's so sweet what does she think
of all of me now all these years later
it's still everyone's like wedding song
what's wild is it has become uh the
number one radio song in the uk right
now get out as they're mourning the
queen um there's kind of a whole new
playlist
um that they um um put into effect um as
the nation is in mourning and all of
them he's the number one song there
right now on the radio which i never
expected and that song has just had so
much life over the years and it meant so
much to us when i sang it at my wedding
but then we released it to the world and
it became everybody's song and it's
beautiful to see
its life just continue to evolve as
people included in all their
celebrations and all their ceremonies
whether it's anniversaries or or or
weddings or whatever it is birthdays and
i'm just grateful and honored that you
know i get to be a part of people's
lives in that way and that we wrote
something um you know we wrote it in the
same way we write every other song we're
just sitting in a room coming up with
something new and you never know what
that new thing is going to mean in the
world whether it's even going to come
out because i write way more songs than
i put out and then only a few of those
become hits and then for one to become
you know one of the biggest songs in
world history really
it's just a huge blessing and i'm so
grateful for it every day well it's
insane yeah insane and when you ask me
what does chrissy think about it you
know
it's hard for her to get the same
emotion she felt the first time she
heard it because she cried the first
time i played it for her
but she doesn't cry every time she hears
it uh she's heard it a lot of times
he plays and she doesn't cry you're like
damn it
it's not hitting you it's been too long
now she's not gonna cry every time but
uh it's still you know it's still always
to mean something to us because we shot
the video at lake como where we got
married
we shot at the week we got married and i
performed it live for the first time at
our wedding so it's always going to be
connected to our anniversary which is
tomorrow by the way uh it's always going
to be connected to that and connected to
us starting our lives together yeah wait
anniversary is tomorrow yes
what the hell are you doing what are you
buying i'm planning a nice dinner for
her okay
from one of her favorite chefs he's
gonna come to the house and and do a
special dinner for us
and uh i have a nice present for her but
she asked for it basically is one of the
things she'll like say john i really
like this and then i'll just write it
down and be like i'll get this for
anniversary i'll get this for her
birthday or whatever or for christmas or
whatever uh the fourth quarter is busy
for my gift giving we got uh well you
know september through december we've
got our anniversary we've got her
birthday and we've got christmas uh you
know
basically
it's a busy time for gift giving
expansive you've made so many iconic
songs but you've also made a lot of
iconic collaborations so i do want to
know
god did
how it came about because people are
like that is one of jay-z's best yeah i
mean it's brilliant and and uh just
hearing him flow for that long in a song
having a verse go that long and knowing
that he doesn't even write any of this
down he's just coming off the top of his
head he's just he's truly a genius um
but uh khaled is great at bringing us
together you know um when we
originally recorded it he told me that
he was trying to get jay on it so he
wasn't even on the song yet and um i
added my piece to it and you know my
part's not even that huge in the song
but it's it's just adding a different
dimension uh especially at the end of
the song
taking it to church a little bit more
but
at the time it was rick ross and lil
wayne i believe and he was hoping that
jay would get on it and not only did jay
get on it but he gave this epic verse
that
the whole world's been talking about and
i just feel honored to be a part of it
honestly yeah you've made a lot of
really great records with kanye mm-hmm
is there any chance
at all
of a reconciliation um
i don't i you know i'm i'm a forgiving
person and uh i don't hold grudges and
i feel like anything's possible and
we've made such great music together and
i truly believe he's one of the most
gifted producers i've ever been around
and just one of the most
interesting creative minds i've ever
been around and uh
i'd have no problem with us getting back
together and making some more music
we
had some disagreements and they were
usually about politics but i don't feel
like that needs to get in the way of
people creating together and
collaborating together so we'll see what
happens